a vote from a trade deal back in 2014
bought Ukraine closer to Europe but has
yet managed to strengthen its struggling
economy at the European Parliament a
three-day conference full of meetings to
find solutions performed by Europe's
eastern neighbor di Bao home indecent or
balance at ninian merely banana Stabila
al Qaeda the reformer country have such
a big transformation process and at the
same time fighter enemy which has
occupied part of your country that the
thing is an incredible job but we have
to be helpful that they can achieve the
goals the large delegation of Ukrainian
parliamentarians included their chairman
ridhima Gausman yeah because I'll show
miss just awesome my boo doing more I'll
give no problem in yellow he was a chimo
spinny spinny plan G Zara's no cranes
competition am we will speedily plan G
bukistanian dosvedanya Shakira pesky
partner if he knew Petrenko shoulder
reform Ukraine's call Parliament
Christie Parliament my state approval no
you
Democrat each new user can adapt to you
your basements to do too vain for mr.
Guzman the ball lies in Russia's court
to bring stability to the region